YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Your application
is running on Google
Cloud, automatically
make some metrics available
through cloud monitoring.
But there may be
times when you need
to add custom telemetry
to your system for better
observability.
Today, I'll show you how to use
OpenTelemetry to do just that.
This is "The Stack Doctor."
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Previously, we covered
using OpenCensus for custom
metric instrumentation.
That project is merging
with OPENTRACING,
and the next major release
is called OpenTelemetry.
It's a single set of
APIs, libraries, agents,
and collector services to
capture distributed traces
and metrics from
your application.
Today, I'll show you how use
the metric functionality.
Let's take a look at
a specific example--
a web server written in Node.js.
We want to collect the golden
signals for our service--
how much traffic we're
seeing, expressed
as a request count, how
many errors we're returning,
and how quickly we're able
to respond to requests,
expressed as response latency.
You can read more
about golden signals
in the Monitoring
Distributed Systems
chapter of the SRE book.
We'll link to that below.
Let's get into the code.
As always, we'll link to the
repo in the episode notes.
For this example,
we'll send the metrics
we'd like to Prometheus,
which we covered
in the previous episode.
First, let's import
the necessary packages,
the opentelemetry/metrics
package
and the exporter-prometheus.
Next, let's define the
metric we want to capture.
Request_count and error_count
are monotonic counters,
meaning that we can only
increase their value.
This makes sense, since the
total number of requests
and errors only goes up.
Latency is a
non-monotonic gauge,
which means it can
go up and down.
Our latency will be
different for every request,
so we need to be able to
set its value directly.
Finally, we're ready to
add values to our metrics.
For our monotonic counters,
we can use the add() method
to increment them every time
we get a request or throw
an error.
For the non-monotonic gauge,
we can use the set() method
to explicitly set the
value of the metric.
We're now ready
to deploy the app,
making sure to properly add the
Prometheus scraping annotations
to our deployment spec.
Once that's done, we can
access the Prometheus UI
and graph our metrics.
We can now see how
much traffic our app
is seeing, how reliable it is,
both in terms of availability
and performance.
I hope you've enjoyed
learning about how
to use OpenTelemetry to
instrument your service
with custom metrics.
I'm very excited about this
great open source project.
It's still early, which
means that features
like a native Cloud Monitoring
exporter for metrics
are still being developed.
But that shouldn't stop
you from using it today.
Thanks for watching.
Come back next time.
This is "The Stack Doctor."
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]